hello everyone and thank you for joining
us for part two of our three-part immuno
oncology series today's live broadcast
advancing precision immunotherapy
through next-generation sequencing of
t-cell receptors part one it's presented
by dr. Timothy Looney staff scientist
bioinformatics Thermo Fisher Scientific
I'm Christina Jewell of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational webcast is brought
to you by lab roots and sponsored by
thermo Fisher Scientific for more
information on our sponsor please visit
thermo Fisher comm now let's get started
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I'd now like to introduce
our presenter dr. Timothy Looney dr.
Looney is an accomplished computational
biologist and immunologist with
expertise in methods and applications of
B and T cell receptor sequencing
including biomarker discovery and assay
development he is currently a staff
scientist and informatics lead for
immune immune repertoire sequencing
within the clinical sequencing division
at Thermo Fisher Scientific dr. loonies
interests and specialties are centered
around the repertoire analysis for
immuno oncology autoimmunity and sexist
disease translational research dr.
Looney you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for that very nice
introduction as mentioned I'm going to
talk to you today about the sequencing
of t-cell receptors and if you put in
for the previous installment of this
webinar series you you may have been
introduced to our immuno oncology
portfolio there are four acids within
this amino oncology portfolio the on
combine immune response research assay
which is a targeted gene expression
profiling assay meant to allow one to
understand the tumor microenvironment
there's the uncle mine tumor mutation
load assay for profiling tumor mutation
and then what I will focus on today T
cell receptor sequencing in particular
our uncle mine TCR beta lr assay the L R
stands for long read and in the next
installment of this webinar series I'll
discuss the TCR beta s RFA which is our
short read as a compatible with FFPE
preserved materials so to put everything
in context in our and our broader
strategy and immuno oncology I want to
introduce the concept of checkpoint
blockade immunotherapy and this is an
incredibly exciting development for the
treatment of cancer checkpoint blockade
immunotherapy describes the use of
agents that modulate the way in which T
cells interact interact with immune
cells and tumor in order to increase T
cell killing a tumor when it works it's
incredible there's a durable response
and in some cases and an individual
cancer is totally cured what is
potentially even more exciting is the
notion that one can use these blockade
agents in combination to further
increase the efficacy of this
immunotherapy treatment
so one question is whether or not
someone will respond to an immunotherapy
this is this is something predicting
response is something that is an
outstanding question in the field now
that despite the the efficacy and and
excitement with this approach there is a
challenge which is immune mediated
adverse event and when one received
checkpoint blockade therapy that can
activate T cells to destroy cancer but
it can also make those same T cells
destroy healthy tissue and immune
mediated adverse events or immune
related adverse events can affect
multiple organ systems and cause
permanent damage or even death and
what's what's more is that the incidence
of adverse events is elevated in in
combination immunotherapy setting thus
the sia therapeutic approach that holds
the most promise may also have the
greatest challenge in terms of toxicity
and today there isn't a good way to
predict who might have a very bad
reaction to immunotherapy and who might
receive checkpoint blockade without
problem so if if one could identify
biomarkers predictive biomarkers for
adverse events that would allow for
safer and more effective use of
immunotherapies potentially allowing for
personalized drug selection and dosing
and ultimately expanded use of the most
efficacious combination therapies so at
a thermal Fisher I you know I want to
mention that that we are we have taken
these these questions to heart we and
much of our work has been focused on
identifying predictive biomarkers for
adverse events during immunity in
immunotherapy but also predictive
biomarkers for response and in the the
following slides in this webinar I hope
to show you how T cell receptor
sequencing of peripheral blood can
used for to address both of these
questions
you
now in terms of the amino oncology assay
portfolio this this portfolio was
designed in order to interrogate all
aspects of the cancer it immunity cycle
and this details the way in which T
cells and other immune cells interact
with cancer in the diagram here you'll
note the at the bottom a visualization
of the tumor microenvironment
and in the tomb the tumor
microenvironment is a perfect type of
material to interrogate with the uncle
mine immune response research assay
which is a targeted gene expression
profiling sa tumor may also be profiled
using the online tumor mutation load
assay and antigen presenting cells may
prime T cells with Tornillo antigen
which may proliferate and then
ultimately kill tumor I'll point point
out to you in this in this immunity
cycle the ultimen TCR beta l our assay
it's on the peripheral blood portion of
the immunity cycle and this assay is
really ideal for interrogating T cells
within the peripheral blood these are T
cells that may have been primed by tube
terminal antigen and proliferated and so
within the periphery one may detect
signatures of t-cell responses to tumor
you
so in this next slide I'm giving a
little bit more detail in the T cell
receptor biology the T cell receptor is
a heterodimer consisting of a beta chain
and an alpha chain which are produced by
vdj recombination and during this
process
tandem li arranged variable diversity
and joining genes we combine to produce
a functional receptor owing to the
combinatorial nature of that process and
the action of EXO nucleotide to back at
the ends of the VD and J junctions and
addition of non templated bases by T DT
the CV are three region is incredibly
diverse it's so diverse that it can be
used to track a T cell over time with
that said the CDR one and two regions of
the rearranged receptor are also
important for determining the antigen
specificity of the receptor and this
portion of the receptor is germline
encoded and what I'm going to describe
to you in the in the later slides is how
polymorphism within this germline
encoded portion of the variable gene may
serve as a biomarker for adverse events
so this slide highlights the essay
design of our TCR beta chain sequencing
assays we have developed an L R and s RS
a LR refers to long read and it's a long
amplicon an SR short reads short
amplicon covering the CDR three
now the the CTR 3 essay the short read
assayed owing to that short amplicon
length allows it to be compatible with
FFPE preserved material where the
nucleic acids may be degraded by
contrast to LR a say you'll note at the
top you de lutte utilizes multiplex
primers targeting the framework one
region of the variable gene and the
constant chain region so this produces
an amplicon of approximately 330 base
pairs in length that includes sequencing
coverage of all three CDR domains not
just the CDR 3 which can be used to
track cells and measure clonal diversity
but also the germline encoded CDR 1 and
2 regions of the receptor
now both of these assays can be analyzed
in ion reporter which is our software
our nm analysis platform and this
includes a number of analyses that allow
one to quickly get a sense of immune
repertoire features this includes
visualizations of the repertoire which
allow one to quickly get a sense of the
extent of clonal expansion or diversity
it allowed that the software allows one
to track clones over time so
longitudinal tracking of clones
and I'll note that the the data produced
by this assay is freely available to
customers you have access to the raw
data and the this analysis can be run
locally on your on your ion a reporter
server or on or cloud so in a part from
the analysis which is you know a great
part of this of this tool we did a lot
of work to ensure that the assay is
producing accurate and sensitive readout
of the Clones within a sample and one
way we did this is by creating a set of
references reference rearrangements
derive from literature here I note the
the details of this of this procedure
where we used 30 TCR beta chains derived
from t-cell lymphoma cell lines the 30
that I mentioned were actually used to
validate the biomed to TCR beta primer
set we took the sequences of these beta
chains clone them into plasmids and then
use those plasmids to spike in to PB l
peripheral blood loop side background in
order to assess the sensitivity of this
assay now in this slide you'll note the
results of that experiment on the Left
I'm showing you the the results of
spiking in those 30 reference
rearrangements into a background of cDNA
derived from peripheral blood leukocytes
and asking whether or not one can detect
those reference rearrangements over a
range of input frequencies and so you'll
note that the frequency of these
reference rearrangements matches
expectation and the assay can detect
rearrangements at over all over a wide
range of normal frequencies
on the right you'll note a complimentary
experiment to demonstrate the accuracy
of this assay in this experiment we we
sorted a defined number of T cells
extracted all of the RNA from those
t-cells and then use that for library
preparation now in this case you don't
know the sequence of the rearrangements
but you know the maximum number of
rearrangements that one might detect for
example if one sorts 5000 t-cells
extracts all of the RNA and then
sequences the T TCR beta chains one
shouldn't expect this to find far more
than 5000 unique rearrangements if one
did that might indicate that there are
errors or artefactual rearrangements
owing to sequencing or PCR error so what
you'll note here is that over 3 or over
a wide range of t-cell input amount the
assay reports a number of unique
rearrangements or clones detected
closely matching what closely matching
expectation
so now I'm going to switch into the
biomarker applications and I think this
is this is a really exciting portion of
the talk
after I cover biomarker I'm going to
then discuss applications of this acid
t-cell therapy
now this this slide highlights two
important biomarkers that one can obtain
from using the TCR beta LR assay on
peripheral blood and you'll note on the
left is the results of centrifuging
peripheral blood you'll note the plasma
fraction the buffy coat which is what
the white blood cells where the T and B
cells can be found and then the
erythrocytes and when we typically think
about liquid biopsy we think about
sequencing material within the plasma
fraction and the buffy coat may be
ignored now what one can do with this
assay is extract total RNA from that
buffy coat and use that RNA as input for
library preparation through the LR assay
and that allows one to do two things
measure TCR convergence which may be a
biomarker of a predictive biomarkers of
clinical response and I'll talk about
that more but also assess variable gene
polymorphism and there's a thought in
the literature that polymorphism within
the germline encoded portion of the
variable gene may be linked to
autoimmune disease and potentially
toxicity during immunotherapy
so just a reminder of the LRS a and the
amplification strategy as I previously
stated this uses multiplex PCR primers
targeting the fr1 region of the variable
gene and the constant gene region that
allows one to detect polymorphism within
the variable gene but also assess the
CDR free region and
I'm highlighting right now the domains
of this of this amplicon and how they
may be used polymorphism within the
germline encoded portion and in the CDR
3 region is is essential for measuring
TCR convergence which which refers to
the phenomenon whereby t-cells t-cell
receptors are identical in amino acid
space but distinct a nucleotide space so
in a typical use case of this assay is
twenty five nanograms of cDNA derived
from peripheral blood total RNA
sequencing sequencing the resultant
libraries to 1.5 million reads it reads
depth and that turns out to be about
eight samples per 530 chip and I want to
mention that the reason we are able to
sequence such a long amplicon is is
owing to the fact that the ion gene
Studio s5 530 chip allows for quite long
read lengths up to up to 600 base pairs
so this assay is really you could argue
is enabled by this unique technology
that the 530 chip provides
so in the next slides I'm going to show
you some data demonstrating the that
these two biomarkers may be used to
predict response and the data I I will
present to you is derived from 55
individuals who receive checkpoint
blockade mono therapy for cancer they
they received either it be if you live
no map Nevada map or embolism map these
were almost entirely Caucasian 54 or
annotated as Caucasians and one of
unknown ethnicity and these the sample
was pretreatment peripheral blood twenty
five nanograms of cDNA and the resultant
libraries were sequence to 1.5 million
read reads depth using the S five five
thirty chip and this this experiment was
performed through a third-party omniseek
and the samples derived from Roswell
Park Cancer Center and to the right I'm
showing you a breakdown of this the
details of this cohort you'll know that
there's a range of cancers mostly
melanoma and adeno carcinoma but some
others and then at the bottom repertoire
features this highlights just the fact
that the samples were sequenced the
sequencing quality was good we received
we obtained about 1.5 million raw reads
per library so to talk about this
polymorphism concept I I also want to
bring into discussion the concept of a
haplotype and a haplotype is a set of
DNA variations or polymorphisms that
tend to be Cohen aerated
and this can be owing to genetic linkage
or population structure now the the TCR
beta locus is a classic example of where
one would expect to detect a haplotype
type structure because there are
polymorphic variable genes which are in
close genetic proximity and because this
assay allows us to detect all of the
variable gene alleles within an
individual's repertoire we can infer the
haplotype from the data generated by
this assay and and thus we can act we
can ask whether particular haplotypes
are associated with severe adverse
events during immunotherapy and in this
slide I'm highlighting a cartoon example
of two different haplotypes where the
the boxes indicate genes the star
indicates different variable gene
alleles and the color indicates what you
know did the actual allele and you'll
note that with a haplotype one expect to
see sets of Co inherited or coincident
alleles
so in order to determine the variable
gene alleles present in an individual
wheat it's it's actually quite
straightforward from the standard ion
reporter analysis workflow and after the
fr1 framework one constant gene
multiplex PCR there's a sequencing there
sequencing of the resultant amplicons
there's a step to eliminate PCR and
sequencing errors and this takes
advantage of the fact that the Ion
Torrent
has a very low substitution error rate
and substitution errors are problematic
for immune repertoire studies owing to
the fact that they can mimic the natural
variation in the repertoire after that
error elimination step there's an
annotation step where the rearrangements
are annotated by comparison to the IMG T
database now IMG T database is
considered by many to be gold standard
but it's nonetheless thought to be
incomplete and what thus when annotating
by comparison to the IMG T database one
also has to have a procedure to identify
instances where an individual may have
an allele that's not in the IMG T
database
so that we can really take advantage of
this long amplicon approach where the
germline encoded portion of the variable
gene is included in the in the amplicon
along with the CDR 3 and in instances
where an individual has an allele that's
not in the IMT D database it will
manifest as a plurality of clones having
a systematic mismatch the IMG T database
over the variable gene portion so
multiple clones each with a readily
distinguishable CDR 3 nucleotide
sequence all having the same mismatch to
reference and we know that if we observe
a plurality of clones having a mismatch
then that indicates that there must have
also been a plurality of unique template
molecules representing the the non ing T
allele so in looking at this data in
addition to determining all of the IMG T
alleles an individual has we can also
determine instances whether it's a non
IMG Julia so applying this methodology
to our 55 individual cohort we obtain
something like this this heat map on the
right indicates the distribution of
alleles across individuals this is an
allele profile of each individual now in
the heat map each row indicates a
different individual and each column a
different allele
a red tile indicates that an allele was
detected in an individual and a blue
tile that was absent so you'll note
firstly that some columns have all red
tiles this is an example of a ubiquitous
allele everyone in the cohort had that
variable G allele now other other
columns have mostly blue tiles this is
an example of a rarer allele now you'll
also note this box like structure this
blocks of tiles red tiles that tend to
be found together this is a
manifestation of a haplotype structure
that I mentioned and on the on the Left
i've subdivided the data into four major
haplotype groups based on the patterns
of these Co incident variable gene
alleles now in the left in the next
slide what I'm going to do is project
this data into two dimensions using
principal component analysis and then
I'm going to overlay that projection
with the adverse events annotation of
the cohort
and here it is you'll note on the right
each each symbol represents a different
individual and each color a different
haplotype group and the the symbol shape
indicates the grade of the adverse
events from grades 1 to 4 and you'll
note the red haplotype group
this group consisted of makes up about
30% of this Caucasian cohort and no one
in that group had a grade 3 or higher
adverse event but they appear to be
protected from severe adverse events
now this could have implications for the
way in which you know one might
theoretically one might treat these
people these this haplotype group two
may be more amenable to a combination
immunotherapy approach where there is
higher toxicity they might have in just
a very low risk of toxicity they also
might be able to receive a higher dose
of mono therapy agents and then one can
also ask the question whether or not
whether or not this haplotype group 2
cohort may be at lower risk of chronic
autoimmune disease
so certainly if you have a question
please write please write it down
contact our moderator and we'll review
these at the end of the of this webinar
so I'm going to I'm going to leave it at
this for the haplotype and polymorphism
the what one other thing I just want to
emphasize is that these haplotypes are
germline encoded so one can assess the
the haplotype of an individual at any
point in time it's not as though one
need to assess it at the time of a
toxicity
so in that in that way it can
potentially serve as a true predictive
biomarker for adverse events
now the second concept I mentioned
before I want to discuss in detail is
TCR convergence and this refers to the
phenomenon whereby an antigen
stimulation event may give rise to T
cells T cell clones which are identical
in amino acid space but different in
nucleotide space
and in such instances we know that
t-cells arose independently went through
vdj recombination and proliferated in
response to some common antigen this is
so this is the what the convergent TCR s
refers to and one of the really
interesting things about convergence is
that it may preferentially arise owing
to chronic antigen stimulation rather
than a cute but transient antigen
challenge and the reasoning is that in
chronic antigen stimulation the pool of
T cells that might that have a chance to
be stimulated by the antigen is far
greater in the context of chronic
antigen stimulation than acute the
transient answerin stimulation and for
that reason convergence may be a great
way to get a sense of the immunogenicity
of a tumor and thus the likelihood that
it may respond to immunotherapy so I
just want to give you an example of what
a convergent TCR group looks like here
I'm showing you an example of a
convergent group three clones detected
in an individual with melanoma and this
is in the pretreatment peripheral blood
of an individual and you'll note that
these three clones are identical in
amino acid space they have the same
variable gene the same CD are three
amino acid sequence but the CD are three
nucleotide sequences are different and
they differ at the VD and deejay
junctions at the part of the
rearrangement that arises owing to
excellent leaflet i2 back and an
additional by the end of the enzyme TD T
and if you look carefully at this slide
at the black bases adjacent to the blue
and the yellow portion of the cg are
three nucleotide you'll note that a
single base substitution a sing
substitution sequencing error has the
potential to create an artifact that
resembles a convergent T TCR group so
for this reason substitution sequencing
errors are
particularly problematic for the
measurements of conversions and getting
back to Ion Torrent and the advantages
of this platform Ion Torrent has a very
low substitution sequencing error rate
and thus it may be particularly well
suited to the measurement of convergence
now we have been looking at convergence
as a biomarker for some time but one of
the first places we looked was in a food
to the sequencing of tumor biopsies and
here I'm showing one slide from data we
presented that AACR of this year and
this study involved sequencing of the
tumor infiltrating T cell melanoma and
this this was using the LR assay and the
the input samples were fresh frozen
tumor biopsies and one thing we noted is
that within them that the melanoma
infiltrating t-cell repertoire
convergent we found ample evidence of
convergent TCR s quite quite different
than what we one observes from the
sequencing of peripheral blood from
healthy individuals so one question we
then asked was whether convergence might
also be detectable in the peripheral
blood and whether it could be used as a
biomarker to predict response so now
returning to that fifty-five sample
cohort when we looked at the
pretreatment peripheral blood for
evidence of convergence we noted that
indeed it appears that individuals who
go on to have an objective response tend
to have a higher frequency of convergent
TCR s in the in the pretreatment
peripheral blood than those who do not
and you know this this emphasizes the
fact that the peripheral blood T cells
in the peripheral blood may indeed hold
signatures of t-cell responses to tumor
and thus can serve as a liquid biopsy
type material for a predicting
immunotherapy response so in terms of
what I just showed you and with respect
to biomarkers for TCR I've talked to you
about convergence and prediction of
adverse events now one question is how
convergence might relate to other
biomarkers for example tumor mutation
burden and
this question is interesting now what
now one can make the argument that in
some ways tumour mutation burden may be
an indirect measurement of the
immunogenicity of a tumor because the
somatic mutation must lead to a change
in amino acid of a expressed protein
that that peptide must be presented by
the HLA and then ultimately has to
engender a t-cell proliferation and
killing a tumor
so there are many steps that have to
occur between the somatic mutation and
the t-cell response but with convergence
were actually measuring the active agent
which is the you know the T cells
themselves so there is an argument to be
made that potentially something like
convergence may be a more direct
measurement of tumor immunogenicity and
finally just to emphasize the data I
showed you from pretreatment peripheral
blood allows for both assessment of
polymorphism for prediction of adverse
events and convergence so with a single
library one can do the address these two
important questions
you
so now switching to the the last section
of this talk t-cell therapy I'm going to
talk to you about ways in which this
assay may be used to improve the
manufacture and and design of
therapeutic t-cells and the use cases
can be subdivided into two major
categories highlighted on this slide
first major use case for TCR sequencing
in therapeutic t-cell applications is
towards the QC or
manufacturing quality control which
allows one to optimize the production of
the t-cells now the second the second
application is to monitor the activity
of the therapeutic t-cells once they are
introduced into an individual asking
questions like how how long did the
therapeutic t-cells persist are they
expanding these questions can provide
insight into the efficacy of a product
so this slide highlights ways in which
one can use TCR sequencing during the QC
product process one can at the very
early steps when one is extracting
t-cells from an individual for in vitro
culture one can assess the repertoire to
understand whether it is diverse whether
there are dominating clones during the
in vitro transient
one can monitor the expansion by
assessing the t-cell repertoire features
again asking whether or not certain
clones are dominating the culture after
a viral transduction step or other event
that alters the genome of the t-cells
it's important to assess whether or not
such procedures may have given rise to
t-cells that are damaged and
proliferating uncontrollably so T cell
receptor sequencing is great for that
and then finally as I mentioned in the
previous slide when those t-cells are
introduced into an individual the T cell
receptor sequence can be used to track
those T cells and ask whether or not
they're expanding or whether they are no
longer found in the individual so just
to to get back to one important
measurements of the repertoire there's
something called evenness and repertoire
evenness refers to the extent to which
clones are T cell phones are found in
equal proportion hi even this means that
the clones found in a sample are all of
similar frequencies whereas low in
evenness indicates that some clones are
preferentially expanded and even this is
also known as normalized shannon entropy
and for those who use clone allottee
it's one minus the clone ality so with
respect to even this one great aspect of
this assay is that one can quickly
within a 48-hour turnaround time assess
the repertoire so start to sample
collections a result can be obtained in
under 48 hours so in this experiment
we sought to track the evenness of
t-cell therapeutic t-cells as part of a
research study these T cells were
derived from peripheral blood
mononuclear cells they were extracted
and expanded in vitro using dynabeads
anti cd3 cd28 ES and CTS optimizer so
this these were expanded over a 10-day
time course and over the the course of
this in vitro expansion we asked whether
or not the evenness of clones changed
and in this type of experiment one would
hope to elicit a polyclonal t-cell
expansion where no one clone is
dominating the the culture and indeed
for two donors so two separate t-cells
starting materials we know a consistent
increase in the evenness of the T cells
over time so this this highlights the
fact that this approach with anti cd3
cd28 bead stimulation and this optimizer
media really promotes polyclonal or
unbiased t-cell expansion
now in this last vignette I want to
mention one way in which this essay was
used to provide insight into an adopted
T cell transfer therapy now the
experiments I'm going to describe to you
was presented by dr. Noel Miranda and in
this study an individual with cancer
there was a tumor extracted to create a
tumor cell line and T cells extracted
from this individual or Co cultured with
the tumor the the goal there is to
elicit that or stimulate the product the
proliferation of T cells that are that
are recognizing tumor antigen after this
in vitro stimulation of those T cells
the the resultant product is infused
back into the individual with the goal
of eliciting and anti-cancer response so
the the individual in question has stage
4 melanoma and previously received
adoptive t-cell transfer and lived for
11 years but the cancer returned and dr.
Miranda had to decide on one of two cell
therapy products to give this individual
and at that time they didn't use t cell
receptor sequencing to assess the
quality of those cells and so he really
had to blindly choose which of two
products to use and you know you can ask
yourself now retrospectively he went
back and asked what was it what of those
two products what would you know one of
the repertoires look like and
on the left the the two cell therapy
products are indicated on the slide till
1207 1209 you'll note that there are
quite striking differences in the level
of t-cell expansion within these two
products the the plots on this slide are
spectra typing plot which highlight
clonal expansion and they're taken
directly from ion reporter you'll note
this oh seven culture on the Left
contains two large circles indicating
two large clones that are dominating
that t-cell product whereas the one on
the right many circles a diverse product
with many unique TC RS now not knowing
which and the diversity of these samples
he chose the O seven and unfortunately
that that individual had a negative
outcome and you know his argument and
with which you know makes a lot of sense
is that perhaps that the 1209 would have
been a better choice because it's more
diverse and thus there are a greater
number of TC RS that could recognize a
greater number of tumor antigens so this
highlights the way in which this TCR
sequencing approach can be used to
improve or understand therapeutic t-cell
applications so with that I want to
finish and just summarize what I told
you in this in this webinar I talked to
you about that the ion gene studio has
fine system and how aspects of that
sequencer the Ion Torrent really are are
well-suited for immune repertoire
sequencing applications namely the low
substitution error rate long read
capability and fast turnaround time of
this this platform I told you how long
amplicons sequencing of beta chains from
pretreatment peripheral blood allows for
interrogation of polymorphism and also
conversions to
we predict response to immunotherapy and
toxicity and then I finally talk to you
about ways in which that fast turnaround
time and low input requirements allow
the teacher beta l RSA to be used for
therapeutic t-cell applications so with
that I think we can turn to questions in
the audience and I really thank you for
taking the time to listen to me
thank you dr. Looney for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar again if you have a question you
would like to ask please do so now just
click on the answer question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll try
to answer as many questions as we have
time for okay let's get started
dr. Looney our first question is how
does the mutation rate of CA cells
affect TCR convergence
could you could you of CA cells could
you help me understand what the better
understand that that term
nope but um Stephen you've submitted
this question would you mind submitting
your question again with a little more
elaboration on what you're asking for
we'll go ahead and skip this question
and hopefully Stephen will submit a more
detailed question for you let's go to
our next question okay
dr. Looney do you see convergent TCR be
signatures in PBL also in acute or
chronic immune activation or disease
great question you know this is
something that we're actively exploring
at this time from from the data we've
collected it does appear that one can
detect some level of convergence of TCR
convergence in in peripheral blood of
healthy individuals but it's typically
less than 1% of the total the total
sequences now in terms of chronic
autoimmune disease this is a great this
is a great question and one could
hypothesize that convergence in this
situation may be elevated we don't know
yet but that's that's a great question
and something that could be explored
further
okay we're going to go back to Stevens
question um how does the mutation rate
of cancer cells affect TCR convergence
oh great this is you know very thanks to
even that's a great question
what and I think that you know the
broader question is how does somatic
mutation or the or the neo antigen load
of the tumor correlate with convergence
we don't we don't know yet that's a
great experiment one could assess tumor
mutation burden and ask whether or not
it correlates with the extent of TCR
convergence in peripheral blood that's
it's a really nice question and it would
be a great experiment okay our next
question
dr. Looney how can you accurately
measure evenness for clinical expansion
when starting from RNA every cell
potentially has a different copycat
Thanks you know this is this is a great
question and I you know this is
something that I think is talked about
in in the field of the repertoire field
quite a bit what are the advantages of
RNA versus versus DNA now DNA you know
it has to have one rearrangement copy
per cell whereas the RNA theoretically
could have the different levels of
expression now this question I I would
say is most pertinent 2d cells where the
expression of the B cell receptor can
vary tremendously depending on the B
cell type for example memory B cell
compared to plasma blast compared to
plasma cell the expression of the B cell
receptor can vary considerably and so
that's something that one would need to
take into account when looking at B cell
receptors given that a plasma blast or
plasma cell may have an outsize
contribution to the RNA tool now with
with T cells it there's really not to my
understanding indication that different
T cell subtypes have markedly different
levels of expression of the T cell
receptor so that that type of issue
isn't as as pressing for for T cell
studies and you know the other thing I
want to mention which is a really nice
aspect of the RNA approach is that one
can use us quite quite a bit smaller
amount of starting material in order to
survey an equivalent number of T cell
receptors that one would be able to
capture through a G DNA based approach
and that's because the RNA is already
enriched for the target the T cell
receptor beta so that's you know I just
mentioned that's a really really nice
advantage of using RNA for this type of
experiment
now dr. Looney is this a safe or liquid
waste samples only or can we use FFPE
also
yeah this the LR assay is not a
recommendation truncated they're
degraded owing to the FFP preservation
so this is for the ideal sample types
for this LR assay our peripheral blood
peripheral blood leukocytes whole blood
cultured t-cells and any fresh frozen
biopsies so really anything that is not
FFPE preserved
now secondly this question next are you
confident that TC RB signatures reflect
from the associated TC ra signatures
that are not sequenced in the assay
given the preferential responsiveness of
TC RB signals do exigence Genesis and or
endo Genesis super antigen
you know I I want to mention yeah that's
great it's a great question I think that
you know one of the points that this
question addresses is what does what is
the alpha chain have to contribute to
this you know one question in the in in
the field is you know what proportion of
TC RS are beta chain dominant and that
that refers to beta T cell receptors
where that antigen specificity of the
receptor is wholly dictated by the beta
chain with the Alpha chain having really
more of a stabilization role so in terms
of the role of the alpha the Alpha chain
that's not something we sequence in in
this assay this is this is a beta chain
sequencing but one could make the
argument that
perhaps even a majority of TC RS are
beta chain dominant where any alpha
chain paired with the beta chain would
confer the same antigen specificity
okay our next question we have so many
great questions coming in let's go with
this one dr. Looney a follow-up to the
RNA versus DNA question would you use RT
PCA consarn
what'd you use rt-pcr convergence if you
felt RNA was easier to use for T and B
cells studies
um what I use rt-pcr convergence I think
I'm uh still a little bit unsure of that
the meaning of that term
you know I mentioned that RNA in general
is I would say is it great it's a really
a preferential source of input material
owing to the fact that one can use a
small amount of the material to survey a
great number of T cells so I you know
the other thing is that it's it's easy
to obtain RNA usually from from most
samples and it the other the other
benefit to using the RNA is that one
will only sequence productive
rearrangements so that in some cases T
cells can have a productive productively
rearranged TCR beta and also an
unproductive and with RNA as it one will
exclusively sequence the productive
rearrangements well I don't know if I
have addressed that question but if
there's if the if the Aster would like
to follow up with a little bit more
detail of the rt-pcr i'd be happy to
answer
excellent now we have time for a few
more questions we'll try to get a couple
more in let's go with here we go dr. Lee
what is the read length of this essay
yeah the the amplicon length is 330 base
pairs and that covers the CDR 1 2 & 3
then and this is obtained using
framework 1 and constant gene targeting
primers now the a say that those
amplicons are sequenced with the S 5
5:30 chip and that that chip has an up
to 600 base pair sequencing light so
it's ample ability to sequence through
this entire 330 on average base pair
amplicon
okay and dr. Lenny we have time for one
more question is this a say only
compatible with the ion 530 chip no
that's and that's a good question
because it really it's essential for the
long read lengths but the 520 and the
510 are also certainly can be used and
the difference between those chips is
just the output so in for you know the
experiments I showed you we use the 530
that allows one to tip for typical use
cases to have eight samples multiplex
per chip at at level of 1.5 million raw
reads but certainly you could use those
other chips
dr. Looney for your time today we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
dr. Looney would you like to leave us
with any final comments yeah I would
I'll just mention that today I talk to
you about the LR assay but in the
upcoming webinar we will focus on
applications of our SR short read SACD
are three only which allows for an
interrogation of FFPE treated material
it's going to be really nice we'll have
some some exciting data to show you and
I would love to have you there for the
for the next installment
thank you dr. Looney now before we go
I'd like to thank our audience for
joining us today and for your
interesting questions now any questions
we did not have time for or those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by dr. Looney via the
contact information you provided at the
time of your registration at the end of
this webinar you will be redirected to
the registration page for our third
webinar in our three-part immuno
oncology series titled advancing
precision immunotherapy through
next-generation sequencing of t-cell
receptors presented again by dr. Timothy
Looney this live webinar is on September
12th at 8:00 a.m. Pacific time this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
February of 2019 lab routes will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's slide event we hope to
see you on September 12th until next
time goodbye
you